this is going to be the most important
lawsuit that we've seen in Ai and
Technology ever New York Times lawsuit
against open AI New York Times has a
Content Library going back to 1851 the
allegation is that those articles were
used by open AI without consent the
second theory is when you go to chat gbt
and you ask for an article it has 100
instances of somebody putting the first
paragraph of an article in and Chad gbt
gives you the rest verbatim open AI will
win some key points I don't think
they're going to straight lose on the
fair use or at least not without going
all the way to the Supreme Court the
other side of that people who have at
scale copyright libraries you're going
to need their permission ahead of time
and if you've used it I think you're
going to have to unwind it